something TV robby dyrdek big black a  boy big black welcome to our crib  Christopher Boykin known to fans as big  black has died  et can confirm Boykin died Tuesday he  was 45 years old a rep for the reality  star declined to share any additional  details big black rose to fame in 2006  after starring alongside his pal rob  dyrdek in their MTV series Rob and big  the duo also appeared together in the  Robin big spin-off Fantasy Factory big  black I need you to take aim and drop me  before he was a TV star Boykin served in  the u.s. Navy one thing I got to mention  my man here is that is a veteran of war  you know respect to you appreciate  what's he done for this country Gulf War  back Boykin is survived by his young  daughter he posted this photo last month  taking her to her first concert  [Music]  you  [Music]